[Music]
we end our spring into summer series
this morning with answers to your top
questions about making summer plans now
that we're beginning to return to normal
many of you asked us about face masks
covet variants and the risks for
vaccinated adults and children
cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us with the answers david
good morning
let me get to the first question here
right away from a parent on twitter who
asks
if my kid is fully vaccinated can they
safely go to an
overnight camp where there would be kids
who are not vaccinated
good question yes
the answer is yes yes yes is that if the
child is vaccinated remember children
are responding better than adults to
these vaccines
they are protected even if they're
exposed to somebody who is unvaccinated
so go to camp
enjoy be a kid all right one of our
staff members five-year-old daughter her
name is margot
has this question go margot why school
cooper still
here and why do we have to wear masks
everybody's asking that question margo
that's a big question from margo
margo so i feel bad that people 12 and
older may not have to wear masks when
they go out
and when they're getting together but
unfortunately you do
because we're not yet vaccinating
children under 12.
we're here because this virus is
different than every other virus we've
seen
in that when you feel good you can
spread the virus so people
unknowingly asymptomatically have spread
that virus
and that's why it's taken so long we've
got a question from jessica
a lot of people want to know this test
should vaccinated people
still get tested before and after
traveling
that's a good one and so before
traveling depends on the country you're
going to
many are requiring a negative cova test
before you get on that plane in the
united states
we require at least three days or a
minimum of three days before you get
back having a negative cova test before
you fly back
if you're vaccinated you do not have to
quarantine when you get back
but we're asking that people get tested
three days after they get back to the
united states
what if you're traveling in the states
what do you think about that i know a
lot of people
no i no okay wear a mask on a plane
enjoy it and you do not have to
quarantine or be tested
unless certain states have requirements
hawaii does have a requirement that
they're asking for tests
and there will be a coveted vaccine
exemption but i don't think it started
yet
dr agus frank wants to know can those
who are fully vaccinated but
test positive for covet 19 spread the
virus to those who are unvaccinated
and potentially make them sick
ah frank that's the question this is
based on all the data we have on the
vaccines the real world evidence the
answer
is no and so if you're exposed to
somebody with
covet and you have a small amount of
virus it's not enough to spread to
somebody else
which is why we're saying you only need
to be tested if you're symptomatic
wow that's great news all right david
lisa asks are vaccinated people
still supposed to stay away from places
where it's unknown who is vaccinated
and who is not if you have a normal
immune system and you've been vaccinated
you know the two weeks after that second
shot or after the j
j shot go go to the supermarket go to
events
it's okay you are protected and you are
protected from bringing it home
even if you have young children you're
not going to spread it to them and
that's why the cdc changes
recommendation it's based on data
okay here's heather she wants to know if
a fully vaccinated person
is exposed to a variant will they still
experience symptoms
and can a fully vaccinated person get
coveted
so right now the three vaccines that are
approved by the fda within eua
all protect against all of the known
variants from serious illness
there's a small percentage of people
that when exposed to a variant will be
what we call the breakthrough cases and
then normally they're just mildly
symptomatic
so in general we are protected from
those variants and that's what's so
exciting
14 and a half months we've been cooped
indoors this summer enjoy
yeah that's music to my ears thank you
dr david higgins